some leaves here in this video I'm
joined by Chris hunter and what's the
legs and we are going to be discussing
the new HMO changes and legislations so
there is a lot of changes going on I
mean Chris tell us what you do and just
summarize what the changes are
we're contractors we change refer
properties from single lakes into HMOs
and main changes are that you you've got
a house never needed to be licensed
you doubt fight that house so two
stories didn't need to be licensed there
was only three three stories now every
five bed house needs to be licensed
bobert HMO yeah five bed hate you mo but
the thing is people think I've only got
a full bed HMO doesn't need licensing
it's a number of occupants we just say
that their fight bed or their for bed
because that's the number of rooms but
it's number of occupants yet so if
you've got a couple in there I mean
three other people you need a license
stuff even if that couple is that even
if it's a form of of that couple is on a
a signal a single a stay yeah it's a
number of occupants per property so a
lot of properties that I hate him as
currently that are unlicensed will need
license it I just gonna be a nightmare
and also not only will they need
licensing but potentially if they're not
being run well safe they're gonna need
fire door smoke alarms in order to get
licensed so it's a real big deal
I mean you know what I think Chris or on
actually a bit of an opportunist and an
optimist are quite excited about the
changes which I'll expect you are as
well look we've already spoke about this
huge before what you're not so happy
yeah I'm not really upset about it but I
don't think it's a good thing because
not not so much the licensing but the
extra rules the extra that we were
talking earlier worried about the sound
proofing situation now it's gonna cost
more money I just think it's a way I
think the government are just hitting
landlords left right and center at the
moment and I think this is just another
thing
should making it harder to run I hate
Tomatoes making more defenses where do
you not think that that where there's a
rule challenge or time and got some
thinking it's oh my goodness we've seen
it happen again and again we've got to
before there's usually a plus side and
actually ultimately when you know what
you're doing they can make more money
from that I think there usually is but I
do
I can't we see a Poseidon this what
you're just really upset
there is your shun I'm not really upset
but what how you feeling what you
feeling there I'm just like I just think
that they are trying to solve if they
can get rid of the hate you know market
there just makes me a market condo can
it because it's a great product people
need to read cast go but what they can
do is that the moments very very
profitable and what they can do is they
can slowly make it less and less
profitable Chris what do you look got
what you thinking they're not trying to
get more money out of landlords they're
trying to get rid of the bundle bad
landlords you haven't got to do it
obviously so I'm keen on it because I
think whereas before we we would have to
refer the house and you'd get nailed
down to just doing the barest minimum
now we can actually provide a really
nice home not only does the investor
make more money because he's got a far
higher class property yeah
but the tenants they're gonna be a lot
safer and if and it's not just arson
it's not before you had the local area
we want this we want that you had a 2004
Housing Act that made you basic
guidelines and you had your local
authority you added and they could come
in and nobody was sure what they're
meant to do now you've got these much
mister national legislation everybody
across the country all the contractors
all landlords have got a stick to that I
think that is a good thing because you
you can't have some little Authority
I agree with them I think they think I
guess it depends on who what sort of the
coin you look at this how is how the
change is going to affect people so I
mean you're you're looking at this
from your point of view or from the
investors I'm not sure I mean house
let's just start how's it going to
affect investors here will investors
it's gonna affect them because it
basically just means that it's gonna
cost more money
- yeah hate you buy at the moment the
rest usually typically of my hair Khmers
that would last - you assume that the
house is in really good condition number
cost about three to five grand
for you to put fire or smoke alarms get
it to get a decent that's it you've told
me that's gonna go up a little bit now
not a little bit it's not a little bit
is it why is it so what is it going up
so much well let's hear it for the man
himself then to work so you're saying
like so we say down to five things to
tell me you sell your house we're gonna
need to provide or smoke alarms you know
and make it maybe maybe put some
father's head windows if the roots are
and typically it used to cost about
three four five plans to do all the
compliance safety HMO stuff and that's
what I spend what's different now
okay now the actual building work is not
going to be much more for what you've
asked for Theodore smoke alarms but they
insist on soundproofing all the rooms
and so you have to put in suspended
ceilings because you will not get a
license unless the property is
soundproof between rooms so one below
one above and also next to each other
yep so that increase your costs you're
looking for a suspended ceiling you're
looking complete plaster and everything
you're looking around 60 pound a square
meter yeah including the plastering of
it afterwards yeah including the plastic
but so you work that will increase but
the main point is where your costs of
conversion increase you have to pay
building control you also have to pay
for same testing you have to have a fire
risk assessment there is no way would
you do that
my properties we do we always recommend
and for our properties we always insist
on it but this is across the board now
these are for the landlord to see okay
see you see I think that they've gone a
bit too far
I think fire risk assessment that should
be in the legislature when you things
like Gregg bill happening just beyond my
goodness yeah oh you want you want it to
be totally safe yeah but making the
sample so now we're talking Robin sort
of four grounds to the eight Grandal no
not quite
brandy it with your with your fees on
top now that you've got your you've got
your license your building control yeah
yeah it that's why I'm saying it's not
so much a building it's all the people
who have got their finger in the pine
yeah officer the licensing coming out so
do you think now Chris if I said I kind
of just bought property now forget the
ones previously how much is it gonna
cost to just get it compliance in good
condition how much do you think roughly
Bob will be talking I be saying a
minimum they'd really it's a bit of a
pain yeah there is a good side to this I
mean well I'm looking to get tell you
where I'm looking to go wrong because
but obviously it just takes you up they
happen to get sound truth it's like why
yeah but I'm looking at it from a from a
sourcing point of view yeah and when you
packaging a deal and you're looking at
it in its lawyer the figures now unless
so basically what's right he's making it
hard now we got put like speaking to
Chris is like that that was 9 grand
that's gonna make it it's less this it's
harder to get into now before it was a
case that I use by house went out we've
got room no big 8 now you've got to be
compliant you've got to do all these
things principle I agree with compliance
the fire safety is but it they've gone a
bit too far
I wouldn't know made it a bit too
expensive yeah but yeah although you
know is annoying but what yeah the thing
that gets me is the people who got their
fingers in the pie building control
mover you ring them up for advice and a
we've we've been on one
we run build and control we've come up
with this scheme that scheme you have a
scheme for soundproofing and they say ah
just do what it says in the book yeah
and you thinking now I'm asking you for
advice I need cheaper alternatives you
know and one of the things that has come
about
under the Sankranthi and the sound test
afterwards is everybody thinks I'm just
going to put down deeper underlay and a
thicker carpet in the room above the
same test has to be done without any
carpet yet carpet an underlay our
soundproof our soundproofing techniques
yeah but you cannot do that so Chris why
do you think it's why you certainly
thought it was brilliant many changes
why are you so pleased well it's such a
pain for people like Russell and
investors and investors because the
thing is you're thinking from a sourcing
what gives money back you know from an
agent with all these investors that were
buying HMOs or passing you work yeah now
they're gonna go oh I don't think I can
afford I hate tomorrow and you're gonna
get let's work from you letting agent
and from the sourcing port is just a
plane so I can investing myself well I'm
not sure about that we'll talk about in
a minute but what worry what are you
thinking Chris why are you happy about
it well it seems to be such a pain all
the programs she I'm telling rogue
landlords all that sort of thing this
just stumps them straight out and
blocking sorry that was the case anyway
surely that will if there's a lot of
roadblocks their age there is but why do
they are in the sands having to register
HMOs and avid and sorta license agent
knows I think that makes sense but why
change the rules as well why not just
keep it as it was but make everyone
realizes because P that would do the
same thing but how many how many HMOs do
we look at that aren't up to scratch
you're not licensed no well then they
are like how does this will help it
doesn't even the license
we are just applies some license process
and I'm thinking well how did they ever
get the license so they are very easy to
license properties I mean war
- really are going to some properties no
calm but leave they've got lost is that
because the rules are wrong will the
people are following the rules people
are no well some people are following
the rules I mean the good thing the good
thing about the change is one overall
pate is because we we already even for
the unlicensed properties and this
doesn't affect for better properties
doesn't unless them but more so this is
only for five bed before you needed to
get a lot of sense if there was five
people over three stories or more now at
the same is five foot stuck you know if
it's four days actually doesn't look
like although it might one day it
probably well yeah well we what we're
trying to do is even on four bed because
we know the way rules are changing it
has to be free story now it's five bed -
we know it's gonna be for bed whoever it
comes in next year so I feel like we've
prepared for this really make it work
better this is it but not the
soundproofing we not know the
soundproofing is the only thing but
that's that's my main main client but
here's the thing so I'm an investor's
point of view now all upset from a
sourcing point of view because you think
if less people are gonna get into HMOs
now there's a higher entry point yeah
but from an investor's point of view I
mean you're an investor I'm an investor
from an investor's point of view is it
not actually good because we're already
running uh properties to a good high
standard gonna cost us next Republic man
to get soundproofed but there's gonna be
so much less competition
mm-hm there's gonna be so many
protecting their properties that a rogue
that are taking up space on spare room
who are going to turn their properties
back to single that's the sourcing
business might suffer but that's that's
a small a small issue compared to our
own I do I do think from an investor's
point of view get rid of rogue landlords
is good yeah so you've got to look at it
as a big positive sign from the talents
point if you can't you you because I
just look at it from an investor's point
of view sort from a letting agents point
of view or from a sourcing we need to
look at this one from an investor's
point of view which is where we do make
most of our my and secondly from the
country's point of view
safety tenant standards yeah you don't
particularly it's probably a good thing
yeah also I think the like I like either
way it's going to go is rather than
buying very cheap four bedroom houses in
very very cheap area spread to the knife
for say thirteen fourteen hundred pounds
a month doing them on the cheap I'm
making the money that way what's going
to happen is there's gonna be a lot less
supply of HMOs
I don't think rents are gonna go up the
hata modes are going to be better better
standard so what I'm singing certainly
with my students is that they're now
moving away from very very cheap for bed
houses up north a little bit which is
and then great they work I've got them F
on and they're moving towards higher end
five six bed
HMOs spending a bit more money but then
rather than making three hundred and
fifty pounds a month per room per tenant
they're making four hundred fifty five
hundred pounds a month well we've got
some that we're managing in Birmingham
they they're about a mile from the city
center kitchen an ensuite most of them
are gone that's brilliant
so I think that's the way the investors
are gonna moving now that they're moving
towards swap in higher end spending a
little bit more money down because the
thing is it the only the only figures
that matter it's what you put in what
you get out what you're gonna put in is
good a little bit more but that's always
gonna be the case because properties are
going up I think so you're gonna put in
is gonna be a little bit more but I
think what you're gonna get out is gonna
be more as well yeah and also view it if
the investors putting in more money
getting a higher quality finish and a
better product just couldn't get a
better talent than the better ten will
pay the better run and stay longer
yeah do you think it would be an idea
because also odd person that's a
question of a terrace point of view
let's say that happens yeah and they all
go higher end and the price is there for
all go up what about the people that
literally could only afford the 350 400
yeah well that actually is there a
problem
is there a product there I think sir for
the cheap I was about to say that all
I've got a couple of comments going
through so lots of uh students and
investors that are sourced we've soft
copies for but
being Grimm's burry Grimsby Bradford
Hall for bed for tenants no license
needed no planning permission no bill
demands nothing like that and their plan
was just put you know furniture in
Matthew look nice webmaster Easter day I
think that's still that guy I think you
can still do that all day long as long
guys stick it to four beds stick into
four beds and how long before they bring
the rules in for four beds they will
when I find that there's a demise of the
five and six bed the council's aren't
making the money out of those we'll find
something else to pick on leave the four
beds what ask me the check a wire offer
you exactly what could be yes yeah I
mean how long does it take him for
they've been normally they talk about
things that ever yeah yeah they're
always behind service combination
there's pretty much nothing
yeah bother you could be five years
another think you could do is if you
were buying a five bed and you're gonna
have to spend eight branches on the
compliance and there's not potentially
is you could make sure that it stacks up
as a single lap so you can say I'm not
gonna buy a property let's say you buy
an 80 grand house in Bradford and you're
planning on doing was a four or five bed
hate you know you could say well hold on
a minute how much would I get as a
single that this is what I do
how much could I get as a single that is
it still gonna stack up am I still going
to be making money want as a single that
if so great if not then it has to work
as I came and they're messing with the
rules then that's something I think
you'd potentially to spillover careful
off yeah on one of my students was
looking at property which was an ex post
office it was gonna ruin it as a hate
him out it would never work from single
that you know it was an ugly building
and it was gonna be a full bed HMO and I
said to him isn't that that's not really
great because if it doesn't work as I
hate you know there's no way you it
worth anything else it was just really
ugly or pop little it was only half an
ex post office and it wouldn't you want
to rent it out as a single and no way to
a family so I think it's nice to have an
exit strategy when you're buying a
property so okay this is my plan I'm
gonna do it as what we do that I'm gonna
do serviced accommodation if it doesn't
work
nation hi-yah or if he doesn't look at
that job okay I could potentially as a
single lap if I live is assuming that
I'm going to lose me now rather than
making twenty twenty five percent return
on investment I want only make ten
fifteen but at least I'm not going to
lose money I think that's smart as well
yeah but I really do think though that I
think all they're doing is they're
making it harder for people just
starting out getting it but there are
it's actually can be really good for
investors that are serious the buying
properties are that are trying to be
good landlords and give good quality
home yeah hello it also helps because
we're we're saying oh we're not without
this we're not gonna have that speaking
to contractors up north the number of
properties HMOs suggesting five bed HMOs
just coming on the market yeah because
people don't want to spend the money so
you can buy a property now that's
already built in separate compartments
and needs very little amount of words so
you're setting up yeah and it might be a
good opportunity to get in there now and
then just make them comply okay I mean I
think a lot of these changes as well
like the article four they're bringing
our two before word to an area brilliant
by now and then when it comes in you've
got the grandfather odds but why I hate
you know even if it's a four-bed still
put the finals in in the slow class do
it right and that way for Chan just come
in with that you'll sword you open your
stomach head and shoulders above that's
always the way to do it mmm I think it
is a good rule overall I'm happy because
I think it's gonna raise the standards
and I think that it's going to put a lot
of road on lords and amateurs out of
business the types of properties that
we're sourcing anyway we're telling
people to do them properly so I mean
what a bit I just don't thought I don't
know if I'm being completely deaf
because
role ya know me I'm how many Builder
what about if you if you have a fight
bed
the landlord scared off course of a new
regs coming in yes so he sells it and he
sells it relatively cheap
but it's got tenants could you buy it
evict one Talent have it as a four-bed
and you don't need the license but you
have got yourself an up and running HMO
change one of the bedrooms into a
sitting room there's always
opportunities to make mine to do well
when you know the thoughts when you whip
when you're in the game when you know
the rules
and you're familiar then you can make
money then you can make the most of the
situation when you're not quite sure
that's when you could end up getting
burned and I think one of the things is
probably going to happen is as well it's
doing a lot of people this is why it's
so great having you in the business
Chris but I think there's maybe a lot of
people that overcomplicated it's like
with these new gdpr
yeah people make it real it's not I mean
so come get in so hard when really it's
quite straightforward and I think the
same I think people are gonna make this
so complex and so as if you're gonna
need you're gonna need to spend 15 grand
it was actually come on me a lot of
builders that are making the most of
this I think you know they've a milk it
they're gonna milk it so I think the key
is doesn't investor it to get educated
yeah why don't we actually need and then
to do that I met the most a situation so
I mean Chris you're all fantastic so if
you want if you're watching this you
want to get hold of Chris how would we
get hold of you Chris to understand all
the changes in what's happening
I understand majority of them and what I
don't understand I will soon know
because things are changing I just go on
to our website which is is www.a
sourcing company by low rent high net
great and if you want to learn more go
on training programs and stuff that's
property - investors dover UK so great
thank you so much for watching if you
benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time